this theory is known as the big bang and
it's the most widely accepted story of
the creation of our universe scientists
came up with this Universal origin story
when they observed that every single
galaxy in space is moving away from us
even
today that means that at one point in
time everything could have been
condensed into an infinitely dense spot
known as a
singularity this Singularity was really
hot too other evidence of the Big Bang
is something known as Cosmic microwave
background it's radioactive remnants
from the early days of our universe
remnants that you can only see with the
help of a telescope